[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur le plateau de
dimanche en politique le titre de
l'émission aujourd'hui c'est europe si
peu sexy et pourtant et oui et pourtant
si vous saviez tout ce que l'europe fait
pour vous en bien ou en mal c'est selon
votre opinion alors pourquoi parler
d'europe aujourd'hui déjà parce que metz
et le mois de l'europe parce que les
élections européennes auront lieu dans
un an tout juste femmes et 2019 et puis
parce que emmanuel macron a reçu le prix
charlemagne cette semaine que fait
l'europe pour vous c'est la question que
je pose à nos trois invités présents sur
ce plateau alors tout d'abord patrick
ayache vice président socialiste de la
région bourgogne franche comté en charge
de l'action européenne et du tourisme
sophie montel ex front national
aujourd'hui au mouvement des patriotes
de florian philippot elle est
conseillère régionale elle est surtout
là aujourd'hui présente parce que c'est
la seule eurodéputés franc comtoise et
puis julien p assé le directeur de la
maison de l'europe un organisme chargé
de promouvoir l'europe en bourgogne et
en franche comté alors n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez commenter l'émission sur
twitter grâce au hashtag dit mme paul fc
comme dimanche en politique franche
comté alors déjà quelques chiffres pour
planter le décor de l'europe pour le
moment l'europe ses 28 états il y en
aura 27 quand la grande bretagne sera
parti si elle pas il y à 511 millions
d'habitants en europe et son budget
annuel ses 160 milliards d'euros et puis
nous dans tout ça nous les deux millions
huit cent mille habitants de la
bourgogne franche comté comment on pèse
et surtout donc combien on pèse dans
sept grands ensembles patrick ayache je
vais vous poser la première question
c'est vous qui gérez les subventions
européennes à l'échelle de la bourgogne
franche comté vous déjà vous peser un
milliard et demi d'euros c'est déjà pas
mal oui c'est vrai vous avez raison
on peut toujours parler de l'europe en
chiffres mais ce serait déjà en dessous
c'est déjà bien anglais oui c'est vrai
c'est bien le montant dont nous
disposons par délégation de l'union
européenne pour attribuer les fonds
européens dans tous les domaines c'est
sur cinq ans
c'est sur cette en ces temps et le
budget de la région c'est 1,8 milliard
c'est ça vous fait presque un petit
budget en plus quoi je dis toujours que
nous avons un budget de plus sur la
durée quasiment notre mandat pour
satisfaire les besoins de notre
territoire oui c'est exact est-ce que
l'échelle région julien p as et la bonne
hauteur la bonne stratégie pour gérer
les subventions européennes ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas puisque les régions
gèrent en france une partie des fonds
européens depuis 2014 tel état qui
gérait un tel pour bonne partie des
légataires crois que c'est effectivement
le bon niveau parce que c'est
probablement l'échelon qui est le plus à
même de déterminer des choix des
priorités stratégiques qui seront en
phase avec les objectifs européens il y
à un cadre global européen les des
objectifs de la stratégie europe 2020 et
pour tous aller dans le même sens et
faire en sorte que ces différences de
développement économique puisse
s'atténuer mais il faut aller quand même
vers l'innovation vers la recherche et
d'autres sujets on appellera en détaille
sophie montel vous là maintenant vous
mettez votre casquette de conseillère
régionale 1 milliard et demi c'est pas
mal quand même oui enfin mal à mesurer
ce que vous avez oublié de dire dans
votre présentation puisque vous avez
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
chiffres moi je je pense que vous auriez
dû commencer par la contribution de la
france au pot commun jade et le budget
en 2016 c'était 25 milliards la france a
perçu 11,3 milliards dont la pac pour
l'essentiel est là elle est donc
contributrice nette à hauteur de 9,2
milliards d'euros elle redonne elle
donne plus d'argent sur l europe se voir
soi qu'elle ne pèse encore voilà il ya
un manque à gagner ne férule 2 milliards
moi j'entends j'entends effectivement ce
monsieur ayache se féliciter du fait que
voilà on reçoit des fonds européens mais
très honnêtement pourquoi passer par une
institution par un organisme
supranational pour redistribuer là
français parce que vous parlez de fonds
européens il s'agit en l'occurrence de
l'argent des français français et
d'autre on sait pas dans le pot commun
qui porte qu'on aimerait bien leur parti
on a disons deux européens convaincus
d'un côté et une politique qui est un
peu moins convaincu des bienfaits de
l'europe alors on va voir quand même
concrètement ce que ça veut dire comme
actions sur le terrain direction le jura
un petit village qui s'appelle non
cuisent et ce village a vu arriver des
subventions européennes dans une toute
petite entreprise on regarde
après plus de 180 ans d'existence cette
petite tournerait du jura s'apprête à
vivre un nouveau tournant les cinq
salariés de la pme travailleront bientôt
sur une nouvelle machine un tour
numérique 5 axes
l'investissement représente 65% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
l'europe va financer 20 % du projet un
coup de pouce évidemment bienvenue
de 220000 euros
notre chiffre d'affaires 2010 est de 340
mille euros donc
c'est un gros investissement pour et
sans l'aide de l'europe
on l'aurait fait de toute façon mais
voilà
une sécurité et puis ça nous permet
d'aller dans ce projet avec un petit peu
plus de confiance
grâce à cet investissement conséquent la
tournerie va améliorer à la fois la
qualité de ses produits et la sécurité
de ses salariés tournage rabotage
fraisage perçage la nouvelle machine
réalisera de multiples opérations
simultanément spécialisée dans la
fabrication de petites pièces pour jeux
de société l'entreprise pourra
s'attaquer à de nouveaux marchés comme
les casse-têtes sphérique ou la
coutellerie aujourd'hui on a confronté
beaucoup d'informations sur nos produits
on est en concurrence avec les pays de
l'est et pose pays asiatiques si on veut
se démarquer on doit faire de la qualité
des produits plus précis innovations
numériques haut débit formation
professionnelle ou transition
énergétique
c'est le conseil régional qui distribue
les fonds européens au nom de l'union
[Musique]
alors ce film ont-elles allez dire à ce
chef d'entreprise que l'europe ça sert à
rien bah écoutez je trouve que votre
justement le reportage il est très
éloquent à ce qui met le doigt justement
sur un certain nombre de problèmes qui
sont justement lié à l'union européenne
en tant que telle le monsieur à la fin
nous explique que son entreprise est en
concurrence directe avec les pays
d'europe de l'est dont un certain nombre
sont membres de l'union européenne
puisque l'union européenne est basée sur
le libre échange sur l'interdiction sur
la concurrence libre et non faussée et
donc si vous voulez moi le système de
l'union européenne c'est un peu m des
cautères sur des jambes de bois en
réalité c'est jouer au pompier pyromane
vous parle vous mettez en avant cette
union européenne qui en réalité est à
l'origine de d'énormément de maupas pas
l'intégralité mais la grande majorité
des maux dont souffre la france gall et
lycées l'europe bien évidemment enfin le
système ultralibéral mise en place au
sein de l'union européenne le dogme
ultralibéral soutenu par l'union
européenne effectivement me gêne me gêne
parce que il a créé notamment en france
en quinze ans la france a perdu huit
cent cinquante mille emplois dans
l'industrie et encore une fois c'est
très gentil de montrer ce petit
reportage mais pourquoi on parle de fond
d'une union européenne qui sont
distribués le cet entrepreneur en a
bénéficié mais les torts et tout à fait
la france libre et souveraine on aurait
tout à fait un gouvernement
souverainiste aurait tout à fait pu
distribuer cet argent plutôt que de
passer par justement l'une rue lanoy
déjà je l'aï pas bien l'utilité de
passer par montel ou dix agents
supplémentaires accusés boîte mais
pouvez vous nous indiquer en fait dans
votre propose que vous indiquez c'est
que vous préconisez la sortie de la
région de l'union européenne entamée
afrique cite comme les dégâts vous avez
vu de parler à l'occasion on va en
parler on va après le royaume-uni ne
s'est jamais aussi bien je pensais faire
une émission pédagogique sur l'europe et
en fait on va faire une émission avant
les élections européennes ne se porte
pas ses portes tant il à 1,5 pour qui la
carte attire le plus non cela est
mauvais chiffres pour cent que le plus
mauvais chiffre des 28 les amarres si
vous permet de l'ehpad da mata 2 je
voudrais juste julien pea que vous nous
disiez qu'elles sont par exemple les
réalisations concrètes et des
subventionné par l'europe un bon juste
sur le sur le budget 60% des
exportations françaises se font dans
l'union européenne un quart des salariés
qui travaillent dans les entreprises de
l'industrie travaille à l'exportation
notamment dans l'union européenne
concrètement concrètes concrètement
alors sur des projets
récent on a les transports en commun en
site propre la ligne 3 de besançon par
exemple 3 millions d'euros ou alors à
montbéliard belfort belfort on à la
dépollution de la rodia c'est à besançon
vous avez énormément de projets de
montée en gamme d'équipements
touristiques notamment dans le massif du
jura vous avez plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes sur la période de
programmation qui bénéficieront de
formations pour le retour à l'emploi
pour la montée en qualification vous
avez des laboratoires de recherche qui
travaillent l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs par exemple et notamment et
puis tout ce qui est lié à l'efficacité
énergétique dans le logement social et
dans les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur notamment dans les résidences
étudiantes pour des personnes qui gronde
et des faibles revenus l'efficacité
énergétique c'est la lutte aussi contre
la précarité énergétique alors c'est le
conseil régional qu'on le disait tout à
l'heure qui instruit les demandes de
subventions auprès de l'europe avec
trois fonds va faire rapide c'est le
feader développement agricole et rural
le feder développement régional et puis
le fser le développement social par
exemple la formation professionnelle
devront parler et le feder c'est le
développement notamment en termes
d'emploi alors quels sont les critères
de sélection qui sont importants pour
vous quand vous voyez arriver une
demande de subvention que ce soit d'une
collectivité une mairie un département
une entreprise ou même une association
vous faites comment pour choisir et
c'est de vous répondre rapidement
d'abord c'est la commission européenne
qui fixe un certain nombre de priorités
qui sont validées par rentrer dans les
clous ensuite avec les autorités de
gestion que nous sommes nous affinons
ces critères pour éventuellement les
adapter à votre territoire et tout ça
est fait en concertation avec les futurs
bénéficiaires pour essayer évidemment de
coller le plus possible à leurs besoins
et ensuite nous faisons avec les
bénéficiaires le travail qui est notre
délai par exemple pour l'entreprise que
vous avez montré à l'écran tout à
l'heure c'est parce que nous avons fait
une réunion avec la chambre de commerce
que cette entreprise a découvert des
fois européen et a déposé un dossier et
puis il ya toute l'information régulière
que nous faisons je voulais dire quand
même que vous avez mis en place un site
qui s'appelle europe tirait bfc point eu
une comme union européenne où justement
venir en aide aux gens qui auraient
besoin de subventions il ya du piston
pas non alors c'est impossible
impossible et règle ce même si en a qui
essaye c'est pas c'est pas financer
totalement impossible et en plus je vais
vous le dire ne le souhaitons pas et
donc nous appliquons des règles qui sont
les mêmes pour tout le monde c'est
d'ailleurs pour l'europe montel un
critère la transparence dans notre
gestion c'est à dire que n'importe qui
évidemment la commission évidemment les
membres de l'assemblée de l'union
européenne peuvent venir contrôler car
nous avons un suivi de l'ensemble des
dossiers pour vérifier justement les
celle d'un pays à l'autre d'une région à
l'autre il n'y a pas de traitement
différencié alors vous qu'est ce que
vous en dites sûr il faut signaler qu'il
ya grosso modo c'est vous qui m'avez
donné le chiffre 60 fonctionnaires au
causse et régionales qui travaillent sur
ces fonds européens et qui sont même
spécialisés en fonction de l'aide ou le
feader ou le feder ou le ffs vous vous
en dites quoi ces fonds européens que ce
soit le feader le fse où ils connaissent
de grandes difficultés parce qu'en
réalité on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des
délais de traitement qui sont très très
longs que les deux le fait de monter un
dossier c'est tres et pour la plupart
des personnes que ce soit des
collectivités territoriales ou des
entreprises ou des agriculteurs c'est un
vrai chemin de croix et puis vous
l'avais dit il ya 60 fonctionnaires à la
région bourgogne franche comté qui sont
mobilisés pour traiter justement la
gestion des fonds européens financés par
l'union et bien oui non mais encore une
fois tout ça la gestion des dossiers
c'est trouve à 60 mais ça coûte
énormément énormément d'argent je crois
que c'est la cour des comptes qui a
rendu un rapport en expliquant que pour
d justement ces fonds européens la
distribution de ces fonds européens pour
des dossiers qui vont jusqu'à 50000
euros il ya un surcoût d'environ entre
14000 et 20000 euros en frais de
traitement offre en frais de personnel
pour gérer tout ça et puis monsieur
ayache moi je vais je vais rentrer un
peu dans le détail vous avez rappelé
tout à l'heure le montant du budget de
l'union européenne 160 milliards mais à
côté de ça l'union européenne est très
endetté alors qu'elles ne devraient pas
l'être puisque l appel traîne année
après année ça ne cesse de secondes ça
ne cesse d'augmenter les traits de 220
milliards de râles de rester liquide et
c'est à dire ce sont des engagements qui
ont été pris et qui n'ont pas trouvé de
financement parce que l'union européenne
n'a pu que s'avouer suffisamment
d'argent l'union européenne a promis
d'argent qu'elle a pas donné mais c'est
pire que ça les programmes les
opérations sont déjà en cours pour un
certain nombre sont déjà réalisés ce qui
est on aboutit aujourd'hui en france par
exemple sur les fonds européens à un
système totalement vicié c'est à dire
que pour les faits adhère par exemple à
un moment donné c'est la collectivité
territoriale la région qui va avancer
une part de la dépense et puis l'état
puisque les fonds européens n'arrivent
pas tout de suite
l'état va se substituer à l'union
européenne va avancer cet argent et
après doit se retourner vers l'union
halonen en demandant répondait mais
rapidement patrick harris l'europe n'est
pas endetté puisque la particularité de
l'europe ce qu'elle n'a pas le droit de
semblait justement c'est ce que je fais
mais les râles ces deux langues diront
que la dette dans l'est un point
important est d'ailleurs contestable de
montpellier l'europe dans la situation
actuelle n'a pas le droit d'emprunter ce
qui est fort dommageable vous en tant
que socialiste ça vous embête évidemment
le grand emprunt européen toujours que
les socialistes aiment bien emprunté à
bien leurs ancêtres et le musée riz de
caracul caricaturer pas le grand emprunt
européen que beaucoup attendent mais qui
aurait permis effectivement de
développer un investissement sur toute
l'europe et notamment dans notre pays
nécessiterait que l'europe soit autorisé
à emprunter ce n'est pas le cas c'est
dommage c'est tout ce que je dis je leur
dis pas qu'on va passer à la suite on va
passer à la suite on va écouter emmanuel
macron qui donc a reçu le prix
charlemagne cette semaine en allemagne
le prix charlemagne récompense un
politique qui oeuvrent pour l'europe
l'europe voici un extrait de ce qu'il a
dit aux allemands n'ayons pas peur de
dire oui pour avancer en europe nous
devons à un moment être prêt à bousculer
les traités et l'échangé et de la même
façon en allemagne il ne peut pas y
avoir un fétichisme perpétuelle pour les
excédents budgétaires et commerciaux
parce qu'ils sont toujours fait aux
dépens de certains vont
[Applaudissements]
alors là vous êtes content d'entendre le
président mâcon qui disent ah oui vous
le savez je suis membre du parti
socialiste je ne suis donc pas membre de
mrm mais je crois que la vision de
l'europe que le parti socialiste a et
celle du président de la république
convergent sur bien des points notamment
sur celui ci est donc je voudrais juste
revenir quelques instants sur les propos
de madame monte elle monte elle dit les
fonds européens nous pourrions
effectivement les fabriquer nous mêmes
si nous n'étions pas dans l'europe mais
c'est le principe même de l'europe le
principe de l'europe c'est la
mutualisation entre les états ça veut
dire que le débat il ne porte pas sur
les fonds européens il porte sur le
besoin d'europe ou d'argile justement je
vais vous montrer d'eux deux palettes
qui vont à enrichir le débat à savoir
que en europe les français ont plutôt
confiance en l'europe à 33% et pas
confiance du tout à 56% et puis une
autre une autre palette de chiffres les
français ont une image positive de
l'europe quand ils sont cadres à 52%
étudiant à 51% ouvriers à 30 2% et le
pourcentage tombe à 30 % quand il s'agit
de demandeurs d'emploi donc vous vous
pensé quand vous voyez ci chiffres là
qu'il ya un vrai problème de visibilité
et de désamour de l'eau de l'europe non
mais je pense au contraire que les
français sont tout à fait conscients des
méfaits des dégâts de cette cette union
européenne je suis effectivement
souverainiste je suis donc pour la
sortie de la france de l'union
européenne mais je ne suis je n'ai pas
un sentiment anti européen on peut
imaginer
un mode de fonctionnement avec une
france souveraine des états souverains
des états libres et des coopérations
entre ses états avec des et coopération
au niveau de la recherche au niveau de
la santé comme ça se faisait comme ça se
faisait avant alors le avant pouvait
faire ça mais on veut aussi se battre
mes rizières et alors je vais revenir
sur je vais venir sur votre argument
enfin la gueule mais je vais venir sur
cet argument dessus ayache l'union
européenne n'est en rien n'est vraiment
pour rien dans le fait que le continent
européen son connaissent une paix même
s'il ya eu la guerre en 72 heures depuis
soixante dix ans ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'union européenne monsieur ça n'a rien
à voir vous savez comme à quoi ça c'est
du tout ça c'est dû au fait ça s'appelle
l' équilibre de la terreur c'est dû au
fait que les états membres 1 vous n'êtes
pas sans ignorer qu'en 45 après 45 on
s'est retrouvé dans un système de guerre
froide avec un d'à côté le bloc du pacte
de varsovie de l'autre côté le bloc de
l'otan c'est parce que ces deux blocs
havel armes atomiques que l'équilibré à
julius baer c'est pour ça que le
traité de rome en 57 le 25 mars 57 avant
au niveau du temps de recruter mais ça
n'a pas déclenché ce faisant m nous
allons vous révéler sera donc moins
d'émissions clients sur les stations
la parole à julien p à julien p à les
français n'ont pas confiance dans
l'europe les français ont une image
négative de l'europe quand ils sont
chômeurs ou
ouvriers vous leur dites quoi vous alors
je nuance vos chiffres parce que ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que les
français dans cette même étude d'opinion
juge l'union européenne moderne et
démocratique mais ils en attendent
beaucoup et le problème de l'union
européenne c'est l'effet qu'elle fait
pas mal d'espoirs déçus parce que elle a
des moyens limités vous l'avez dit 160
milliards d'euros c'est l'équivalent du
budget d'irlande là des compétences
limitées on ne peut pas tout demander à
l'union européenne et puis c'est un
fonctionnement qui est lourd qui est
certes solide mais qui est relativement
lourd quant à parler de souveraineté à
montels la souveraineté c'est une
définition c'est une notion assez assez
uniforme et surtout elle me semble assez
ancienne est simpliste un 19ème siècle
denis de rougemont parler de la
souveraineté en disant que c'était le
néolithique de l'organisation et de la
constitution française souveraineté est
telle qu'on peut l'imaginer au 21ème
siècle est une institution rennes si je
vous ai pas coupé madame ont-elles c'est
une souveraineté nous vante celades
l'interdépendance entre des grands
ensembles vous considérez vous que les
frontières que les frontières sont
l'alpha et l'oméga de la souveraineté
mais quand il s'agit de parler de lutte
contre le changement climatique
quand il s'agit de parler de lutte
contre le terrorisme quand il s'agit de
parler de nos voix les visionnements le
trophée visionnement énergétique et je
crois effectivement en l'idée européenne
et à l'intégration européenne d'ailleurs
les fons et ne citerons pas la vente il
quand il parle d'immigration de gestion
de la crise migratoire quand il parle de
multilatéralisme de sécurité défense ils
attendent de lui on va voir un chiffre
s'il vous plaît on va justement voir un
chiffre les souhaitent les français
souhaitent une politique commune
justement sur les migrations à
l'émigration à 67% la sécurité et la
défense à soixante dix huit pour cent un
mot patrick à l'aise parce que là nous
sommes en plein milieu du vrai sujet
vous disiez je reprends un peu vous
propos pourquoi il ya des amours de
l'europe dans deux pays et dans d'autres
pour mille raisons mais en particulier
l'europe n'est pas un carnet n'est pas
incarné par un homme par une femme elle
est incarnée par des institutions et
quand vous regardez l'organisation
mondiale des états chaque état est
incarné par un homme un président un
premier ministre et il ment probablement
une incarnation eu mais justement on va
leur et sophie montel vous êtes la seule
eurodéputés en franche comté est ce que
quand il ya des inaugurations de
réalisation subventionné par l'europe
est ce que vous êtes invités non est-ce
que vous je n'ai pas n'ont pas invité
mais pas mais vous ne pas ne dit pas
vous ne pas non je veux donc est ce que
c'est parce que vous êtes d'un parti
considéré à l'extrême droite de
l'échiquier j'ai déjà un fait un peu un
peu de carottage un peu de sondage
auprès de mes collègues il ya beaucoup
d'action ceux-ci ceci étant c'est parce
je veux dire je pourrais recevoir toutes
les invitations possibles et imaginables
pour faire la promotion de l'union
européenne évidemment que je ne me
déplacerai pas pour sa
seconde de seconde sur ce que vous avez
dit vous avez parlé de la souveraineté
pour vous la souveraineté et visiblement
c'est quelque chose llorente des états
nations et les dents et à nashville sa
mission mais c'est très grave ce que
vous êtes en train de dire vous rendez
compte la souveraineté c'est lé peuple
la souveraineté c'est le peuple il
n'existe pas monsieur p as de peuple
européen il existe un peuple français il
existe mais ce n'est pas c'est tout à
fait différent mais il existe un peuple
allemand il existe un peuple italien les
autres nous faisons des intérêts communs
du total sur tout ça du tout la source
est pour ça que l'union européenne ne
peuvent pas marcher parce qu'il n'ya pas
de souveraineté européenne possible
puisqu'il n'ya pas de peuple européen et
moi je vous entends dire il faudrait
l'inca il faudrait que cette union
européenne soit incarné tout ça mais moi
je ne veux absolument pas de ce modèle
labre actuellement l'union européenne
c'est l'allemagne s'est incarnée par
angela merkel angela merkel mais je ne
veux pas de ce mode-là moi je veux le
-francis bray suivrait je ne veux pas
président de la république français élu
par les français et qui serait quoi qui
est quoi le le le valais de la
commission européenne celui chargé de
recevoir les ordres les recommandations
selon monsieur romaine c'est ce qui se
passe actuellement c'est pour ça qu'ils
aient une défiance de la ruine des
fonctions somme on parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure des travailleurs détachés
je vous voulez moi une quête minutes
justement je voulais vous poser une
question se fit montel donc vous dites
que l'europe c'est pas bien et c'est
vous venez de faire un mandat vous vous
représenter l'année prochaine oui mais
justement mais je rappelle madame direz
c'est le principe même de la démocratie
on a le droit de ne pas être d'accord on
a le droit d'être dans l'eau piste de
dans l'opposition c'est l'europe est
bonne fille co2 d'avoir des eurodéputés
qui s'applique oui oui qui s'appelle son
autorité tout le temps c'est
heureusement heureusement qu'il ya une
force d'opposition heureusement qu'il ya
des gens pour raconter il ya des élus
alors qu'il ya des cellules il ya des
élus pour accorder d'écouté vous savez
en 2005 il ya eu un référendum tout le
monde s'attendait à ce que le projet de
constitution
européens traités caustique ne traînait
leurs auteurs européens passent haut la
main il était rejeté par les français il
a fallu nos sénateurs hainaut et nos
députés aille à l'encontre de la
décision populaire ce qui est un
scandale jouer
avec le traité de lisbonne essaie mais
encore une fois encore une fois il est
je le ferai avec razouk celle-là non la
démocratie parce qu'à ce moment là le
conseil régional je suis opposé à la
politique de madame de madame du fait du
bmc à l'essai de la république en marche
donc si une autre logique je ne devrais
pas non et je devrai refusé de siéger
dis pas que les régions les régions sont
sombres assure email non mais moi c'est
ainsi c'est un échelon évidemment à
supprimer ah ça c'est toutes les
stations de bois c'est la loose
des coûts la parole à madame ont-elles à
l'ifa voudrait un peu la prendre sur le
dernier point qu'il y ait au sein de
représentation française des opposants à
l'europe ça ne me gêne pas celle
exprimée gratien je reconnais le rôle
des députés européens qui ne partage pas
l'idée européenne donc ce sujet ne gêne
pas mais tout à l'heure nous avons à
peine ébauchés la question de l'europe
que nous voulons alors nous avons dit
fin j'ai dit il faut l'incarner il faut
aussi que cette europe ait les moyens de
travailler et les moyens aujourd'hui
jeudi à pédales a dit tout à l'heure 160
milliards d'euros pour le budget annuel
de l'europe c'est le budget de l'irlande
c'est environ entre un tiers à peu près
un tiers du budget de la france donc il
faut que les français et les
bourguignons franco toi qui nous
écoutent et bien conscience de ça
cette europe qu'on imagine tentaculaire
ayant de multiples pouvoirs etc c'est
une toute petite europe une europe avec
peu de moyens est ce que nous
préconisons ces deux choses un peu
chauvine la première nous voulons une
taxe sur les gars fin vous savez google
amazon facebook pour alimenter le budget
de l'europe deuxièmement nous souhaitons
que les états membres acceptent de
compenser le manque à gagner du bric
site par une éventuelle
leur père dans ses relations financières
car c'est à ce prix là que l'europe
pourra assurer la sécurité des citoyens
le contrôle sur frontières madame montel
nous voulons bien avoir un contrôle aux
frontières européennes et rebelles et un
sujet nous par contre même sillage
l'union européenne promet des 100
mesures financières aux états qui
migrants est ce que vous savez je vous
permettez je vous pose une question est
ce que vous savez combien d'européens
vont quitter l'angleterre dès lors qu de
briques site aura été officiellement
annoncé je vous avais ce schiste le
break si je sais pas vous allez me
demander 300 mille quatre cent mille 90
90 mais c'est pas le migrant dénigrant
excusez moi un train vous les aimez
intra européen sinon on va laisser la
parole suivi la ja
je voudrais bien que je suis rien fait à
des brics beaucoup conclut cette
émission a conclu cette émission julien
paix à vos vous êtes le plus jeunes
autour de cette table je m'inclus vous
la voyez comment c'est cette europe veut
à l'avenir beaucoup plus solidaire est
beaucoup plus intégré je crois que nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix les intérêts
les enjeux français sont intimement liés
aux enjeux européens mais comme ils le
sont avec les enjeux allemand aux
chypriotes je crois que l'union
européenne malheureusement on n'arrive
pas à imprimer dans l'esprit des
français particulièrement elle imprime
chez d'autres dans d'autres pays
européens pourquoi y arriver mais on va
y arriver l'union bancaire la lutte
contre le changement climatique
la récente réforme sur les données
personnelles tout le monde est concerné
par ces enjeux qui ne se règle au niveau
européen l'europe c'est la vie
quotidienne des gens qu'on soit d'accord
au comble au cours ne soient pas de
toute façon comme à partir de septembre
de cette année nous parlerons des
élections européennes
je vous promets sophie montel je vous
promets vous aurez le droit de revenir
et dire tout le mal que vous voulez de
l'europe vous je ne sais pas parce que
on va inviter certainement des candidats
qui représenteront
les partis politiques qui vont être tête
de liste dans en france voilà merci
votre attention merci à madame et
messieurs bon après midi bonnart